blackhead podcast special guest in here
representing be more yes seymour
see oh yes i know i'm [ __ ] with you
now yeah whatever
band hunter izzy is here yeah yeah
what's up man [ __ ] it's cool and joining
la enjoying this [ __ ] scenery
yeah um
baltimore obviously
has kind of been buzzing more recently
than because when i was a kid i think it
was uh was it be rich
what was that
records i heard him
it was a lot of club music going on like
back in the day right then like i heard
him be rich i don't really know none of
his music but
one of the
biggest people that was coming from
baltimore was scooter school
but he got killed and obviously shorty
shorty's been doing this thing recently
yeah yeah um and yourself uh we've been
doing a lot of things yeah yeah you've
been doing your thing man what for you
like uh how long you've been actually
making music [ __ ] like i've been i guess
like making money off me making serious
music like i mean
like
i'm gonna say when i got serious with it
because even like even after like when i
um like when i first got serious with it
that's when i got my main buzz i wasn't
even making no music no no money off of
it it's just that's when i got my main
buzz that's like probably like 2017 2018
started dropping like probably like
around the time school to die when i got
my my buzz because he was looking for
the next person at the oh wow
so what do you remember like what
what it was that you feel like was
working
uh just just some
phone some gang [ __ ] honestly like drill
[ __ ] like i used to always just like
because we think it was in a mix so it's
like
i was just always talking about what's
going on this this and that and like i
said it was looking for somebody and i
did like
i did um a song called ben hunter's part
two
with my brother with my um older brother
judd
and that [ __ ] went crazy we had
everybody [ __ ] with it then remember
when that panda [ __ ] came out yeah
designer i did a remix over that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was going crazy yeah that's
almost crazy yeah and i was just i was
just bubbling out anything i was doing
was
just oh yeah and me and my brother made
this song called freak [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] was so turned i'm talking
about all the [ __ ] like
how come on you're gonna suck this d
gonna ride this dick and i'm thinking
like all the [ __ ] just gonna be saying
it like you know what's up but all the
[ __ ] was under you know this thing
i'm like damn wow he's trying to eat
dick well
now they're on only fans no [ __ ] now
they only fans girls
100 um
what's like you know obviously we're in
l.a man and the gang scene out here is
pretty complicated it's okay there's a
lot of politics there's a lot of a lot
of problems there's just a lot of moving
parts um
what's it like in baltimore
i mean i feel like
there's a lot of gang [ __ ] going on for
real but it's like
it's not too much politics like whereas
though because we from the east coast so
it's like this [ __ ] started in the west
coast right in l.a so it's like it's not
like you some you're gonna come from
somewhere else and they're gonna be like
oh well what set is you like [ __ ] not
gonna be really on that tight time like
it's just
don't bother nobody don't walk down the
wrong block like nobody don't know you
because and all you're gonna hear is who
that who that
hey what who's yo grab yo but
[ __ ] like if you just stand out
the way like if you're visiting just
just
go to the harbor or something like go
downtown go to the four seasons hotel
stay down there some [ __ ] like that
because as soon as like as soon as you
ride off and make two turns it's
overweight yeah you in the hood no
[ __ ] how accurate is uh the wire to
like actual baltimore i mean a lot of
that [ __ ] was going on for real but it's
like a lot of [ __ ] to say like man
that's not how the city is
because it's like they're going through
their own type of [ __ ] but like they
were shooting it on on like weird spots
whereas though like you're not really
getting like the whole
view of the city but
that [ __ ] was going on though [ __ ]
getting cracked
putting them in vacants [ __ ] selling
that [ __ ] wow everywhere and he's
getting these phones tab all that [ __ ]
and then like heroin was a big deal in
baltimore for a long time
yeah yeah we still still is
yeah all that [ __ ] going on like heroin
made a mean comeback nationally
[ __ ] it never went nowhere probably in
baltimore yeah i ain't gonna lie they
said they leave baltimore so i was like
the comeback i don't really know about
that but [ __ ] well i don't know
about no no drugs no way
i just remember
remember 50 cent had uh the baltimore
love things yeah baltimore love song and
some [ __ ] yeah yeah
and 50 one of my favorite rappers like
like just grew up listening to him and
always admired like his word his word
play his craft how he do that [ __ ] and
then like
how he excelled to an actor and then now
he's doing his own [ __ ] like making his
own shows and [ __ ] like he he'd probably
the pinnacle of what i want to be in a
career have you tapped in with any of
the ravens like lamar or anybody like
that hell no like no
i don't really i've never been into
sports and [ __ ] like i mean i'm pretty
sure like
i was just in the airport you know and
the athlete i don't even know your name
for real says like oh i thought [ __ ]
that
but it's like i mean yeah like you don't
watch football or basketball
i literally just started watching
basketball because i'm [ __ ] with the
fanduel [ __ ] like be better oh cause
you're gambling yeah but like i don't
watch that [ __ ] you probably shouldn't
be gambling if you don't watch that
no i ain't gonna lie though i'm good oh
so it's like i see some [ __ ] it's like
okay and then you watch a couple games
you feel like i won i won
a couple of times
listen i'm a degenerate so
you probably should just pay for some
picks yeah i ain't gonna lie i'll be
sitting but i'll be following all the
pages for the [ __ ] who'll be posting
the pics and [ __ ] and i'd be like okay
i'm just do this i might leave this i'll
leave that out i feel like that's
unbelievable so yeah let me just what's
the biggest hit you've hit so far not
much
what about your biggest l
[ __ ] no i'm not betting too much i ain't
batting too much like i would probably
lost like more than like the casinos
like when i went to vegas i lost i had
lost like eight bands yeah
i lost 30 grand like last year what the
[ __ ] yeah you've been wanting more money
than me in one day
yeah that's crazy i i lost the eight
bands in that one shout out to uh mike
davis
from the jets who beat the bengals in
week
eight i believe it was oh he the one who
took oh he [ __ ] my life it was a third
string quarterback turned into [ __ ]
tom brady for one game
[ __ ] me out of 30 racks it was a bad
thing crazy i would never do that it's a
bad day man no but i end up making the
eight vans back like probably like
because you know the casinos stay open
all night right so it's like i end up
going like up to the hotel coming back
downstairs yeah went in the eight back
and i left i was supposed to stay for
three days i said i'm gone i'm end up
losing this [ __ ] again yeah for sure uh
so what do you got going on like
musically i know you got a lot of music
out what's it well just give me give me
the rundown latest before we have you do
your thing i got a whole bunch of [ __ ]
going on like i just
i record every day like but what we
working on right now is the project
means still it's like just trying to
work and connect all of
everything so you're doing a whole
project produced by steels yes who's
here yeah he's here
he's trying to play the background and
[ __ ] but he looking like he's being in
the front line like we like we supposed
to be
so um how did you like end up linking up
with the la guys because i obviously
it's it's a whole different through the
culture just through the culture like
you know like
originates it moves on it goes
everywhere and you end up having to pay
your respects and pay your dues like
they got me out here moving correctly
for real like
shout out to f else but just in terms of
like um like how like did they just
reach out to a dm or like how does that
work you know like it'd be like it'd be
days that we celebrate celebrate the
unity we got so it's like you know you
you link up you make connections you get
numbers and if you're doing something
like productive as you're supposed to do
because that's what all it's about to be
productive and put a put make a good
example then you know we do this [ __ ]
together so we
all it is a couple phone calls we set up
some dates and we link up and move
accordingly there it is
what about what's the last music you
dropped like
project-wise project-wise i ain't
dropping a project in so long you've
been doing singles yeah i might i might
do singles i might just
kick back and cool it for a little bit
whereas i could because it's hard for me
to make music when
like all my music is authentic and stuff
i'm really doing so it's like
i don't like repeating myself and keep
on saying the same [ __ ] from the past so
it's like i be having a kickback go to
baltimore for a couple weeks moving
around like i'm in l.a right now and you
have something to rap about
something
like i can't just sit around in the
house all day and just be recording and
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's gonna be starting lying
like just saying anything that's crazy i
respect that sometimes people just yeah
they just get on the [ __ ] and say
anything i remember i seen somebody um
you know the genius little interview
[ __ ] they just talking about something
oh yeah that wasn't true oh that wasn't
true that wasn't true yeah that's
happened a few times oh it was a little
techa oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was like i don't know i've never
shot it i'm just like no no disrespect
to him but none of that [ __ ] but it's
just like i can't say i can't do that
because it's like
anything i rap about it seen or done
right in this life allegedly yeah
allegedly allegedly allegedly yeah
anything that anything that got talked
about drugs or killing something i seen
it never did it there but when they talk
about [ __ ] hoes and just playing
i've done that one
got to clarify that they got to clarify
because they set you up with a rico yeah
you'll be [ __ ] my wife i thought i
was just rapping jesus christ all right
well look man we're gonna have you do
your thing uh
when is the steals project coming out
[ __ ] we still trying to get all the
songs together and we just shot like two
videos yesterday we gonna shoot another
video today oh you're working with yeah
yeah so we can have everything set up
and we're going to the studio today so
and the way i record i do two songs an
hour so [ __ ] we probably [ __ ] around
depending on how many hours we get have
a whole nother project or just a lot of
songs to pick from well there it is and
we have a stills beat for you to wrap
over oh yeah look a little sample he he
fought that [ __ ]
oh damn i just came out
okay
look
i remember i was out there robbing until
the story changed taking [ __ ] i'm
stealing bars call me tory lanez i took
some more today [ __ ] cause i was bored
today for the green we run up with that
heat like out with florida play now i
can't afford to play with you so [ __ ]
place your order want the whole thing
want to have or just take the quarter
and boy don't play with that quarter cuz
i got more than that throw a bullet at
him i'm taking more than my quarterback
and i don't say it my [ __ ] like nike i
just do it so the dummy square but when
they right there they just looking groin
now i'm saying something told me that i
shouldn't do it thought that boy be
lying he'd be rapping all that gangsta
music that's how gangsters do it and i
don't [ __ ] with suckers give a [ __ ]
about your rhymes i don't [ __ ] with
busters you trying to bust a rhyme [ __ ]
i'm trying to bust a nine and put it in
my rhymes cause i did this [ __ ] a bunch
of times and boy don't [ __ ] with my
[ __ ] this ain't no pretty sight
slicing [ __ ] broccoli easily with this
kitchen knife get that [ __ ] and cook it
right [ __ ] i'm on some [ __ ] tonight
that raw [ __ ] a [ __ ] fitting all
the kryptonite
crippling right dummy but i'd turn you
blood how you [ __ ] do that put a
hollow tip right in his mud he keep on
throwing salt [ __ ] i get that boy slug
[Music]
all right
that was hard
[Music]
[ __ ] say
[Music]
when they right there they just look
congruent y'all know what that means
that [ __ ] just look right
hey shout out your social media and
everything oh [ __ ] um
instagram bam hunter underscore
um
that should have gone everywhere for
real that's i'll be on instagram twitter
for real sometimes i'll be on tick tock
all that [ __ ] the same thing though that
was hard man i didn't expect that
because you kind of scared me you were
like man i really i really like you're
like i'm not prepared no but once the
liquor started flowing like i might come
up with some bars and take some [ __ ]
from some other [ __ ] and just there it
is the nice it's a nice gumbo that was
fire man appreciate you pulling up
appreciate that girl